Yes,
we have a foundation and the website,
yes,
dot org.
It's a foundation.
I started a few years ago and we started
it because we wanted to bring self
esteem back to Haiti and currently 7,000
kids have scholarships.
We started something which is called hip
hop,
hip hop for health mobile clinics going
throughout Haiti.
I'm giving people HIV tests,
giving them condoms,
but through music there's also a
children's prison program where we've
went into these prisons,
whether it's kids introduce chest took
over the prisons,
but more beds,
basketball courts and these kids were
reading.
And um,
every time I go down there and tears
come to my eyes because I knew I wasn't
the beginning.
A lot of these kids was in gangs.
Um,
most terrible violence you could think
about a yearly is actually the movement
is really working and it's,
it's the greatest thing is when I look
at a kid and I noticed that
I can rise his self esteem because
someone rose myself esteem.
That's why I'm here as yelling.
Well,
the first thing is
we have a documentary coming out which
is called CRI.
Haiti.
And this is my work on the ground for
the past three years.
Um,
I didn't leave the ground until I felt
that the people on the ground understood
what we was doing and was training.
So I kept going back and forth,
back and forth.
And now I feel like we have great a
great team on the ground.
We have a great ngos,
but to get it,
it took three years of me going back and
forth to Haiti.
A lot of times when you starting
foundations for it to really work,
you have to be hands on for the first
couple of years.
And I'm in in right now.
It's a natural will.
It's.